he jumps up you won't sell like neva you
want some - all right no
[Music]
welcome to untold stories I'm your host
master spots in we've had 12 incredible
episodes in season 1 and what better way
to have a season finale than here in
Miami and South Beach during Super Bowl
week and I'm excited for my next guest
he is a New Orleans native he is a
hurricane great at national champion a
Ravens legend a Super Bowl champion a
member of the NFL 100 a Hall of Famer
and one of the greatest safeties of all
time I hope I'm doing you justice with
this introduction ladies and gentlemen
please give it up read read retirement
reading man retirement is semi football
is a short-lived career you know so I
had you have the plan for you know the
next chapter you know I'm saying so yeah
I'm retired from football but I'm still
around it I'm still doing a lot of
things what all that planning you're
doing you get time to play poor 9 but
now it's the ping-pong table - that's
what you want yeah all right before you
grab that stick now I got I got a gift
for you all right so see you - oh gee
you're gonna pool huh I gotta make sure
- oh gee feels comfortable oh no I heard
you a big cigar aficionado
so ox a he's got some cigars for you
here John - Glenn told me this is one of
your favorite brands you know what I
actually got my cutter in my let me hold
this for you right here what are you
gonna cigars nice placencia is here I
got in the cigars in college man and me
yeah my friend used to go hit golf balls
all the time losing golf balls and I was
smoking Monte Cristo and I'm Arturo
Fuente and Reggie Wayne calm it was like
man I got some premium sticks for you
you know it says so I'm gonna hook you
up and show enough that's what he did
man and it's been good since then are
you go ahead and get cut up sure I do
I got the V and the straight cutter yeah
so you got the V straight I'm gonna go
with a v cut actually I'm a crown cut it
which most people just like don't really
know too much about you don't smoke with
you right here I'm a smoke after
celebrated season why are you doing that
what you lied that go hand gratis -
right - I'll be there straight don't
fall down right Oscar's on the first one
[Laughter]
[Music]
shoot this one ball in the side pocket
just a little touch all right we're
gonna have a conversation you just gonna
play the whole time I could talk and
play talk and play pool all talking play
football I got time for that
I'd lead it for the Divas I'm gonna go
ahead let's hear this Bob I will start
this conversation before we start talk
to you about your career the sports
world been struck with tragedy this week
yeah passing a cup of Brian not only
just in the sports world but we've seen
how it's impacted everyone around the
world
yeah we want to get your thoughts on on
where you weren't on Sunday and how that
has impacted you this week first I mean
prayers out to all that was affected all
the families that was affected and a
bright family you know it's tough man
you know I always say none of us know
the day at the hour when when God will
call us home you know this is a this
place where ant-man is rented we rent in
this place you know this is not our true
home you know and I you know when
somebody passes this is very unfortunate
you know especially when he's young and
I'm a mother and dad got to Barrett a
parents or you know a daughter you know
in the husband man that's that's that's
very hard to deal with you know but
we're left here with the memories that
we won't have and that we we hold on to
and that's the that's the hardest part
you know but all we all we take from
this place is memories that's how you
take when you leave man you ain't taking
no money in taking the jury are you
taking this the memories you know did
you have any memories are you leaving
you're leaving them I mean I grew up
watching Kobe I'm the same age as Kobe
man 41 you know and where I'm from
you don't make it past 14 you know so
I'm grateful to be where I'm at right
now man but I grew up watching Kobe man
since he'd been in the league since he
was in high school you know I mean how
do you not you know watch what he's done
on in off the court you know I'm a big
philanthropist I love working with kids
and in the things he was doing man how
he's transcended the sport you know as a
human being off the court man how you
not watch that you know how you not
emulate that you know I'm always looked
up to the greats
you know Michael Jordan was one of them
it was my favorite player and knowing
that Kobe with Kobe was everything just
like Mike you know and that that's the
feeling I thought like man that's like
losing Michael Jordan you know I'm
saying that's losing the great players
Muhammad Ali you know so very very sad
day for the world you know and it's just
so happened I woke up and read proverbs
1 proverbs 27 and one on that morning
you know and I actually put it in the
arm Instagram the day just proverbs one
you read that you know I'm saying man it
just it helps me you know because when
you experience that all of us being that
it's you know Kobe if you experienced
that in the last year two years five
years some we deal with a difference so
it brings those feelings back you know I
lost my brother when I was playing in
the league man and I know how tough that
is you know I've been this small Texan
with LeBron just you know giving them
words and encouragement and you know you
just never know what somebody's going
through man so I just wanted to reach
out and just say you know I know it's
hard man but stay strong you know
everyone knew about the mama mentality
and the work ethic that he put in not
only on the court but in everything
he applied himself to know I think we
all sort know you for your work ethic as
well and the effort and the dedication
and the attention to details you put
into everything that you that you apply
yourself to yeah what did that come from
man that comes from my parents you know
I'm there see you know it's in you know
but I had a lot of mentors too man you
gotta have a great circle of people
around you if you want to be successful
in life I think if you want to achieve
great things you got to have the right
people in your circle it's who you
surround yourself with I tell us the
kids all the time you showed me your
friends I'll tell you who you are
you know man mr. George padrone was
talking about that last night you know
man and and that's truly what it is I've
always surrounded myself around God
god-fearing people you know and and
follow God in people you know that was I
was a big part of just living you know
my parents were worked hard man my dad
worked at Avondale shipyard for 30 years
my mom worked in kitchens you know for
20 plus years and that's the reason why
I cook you know so I mean just the
things I knew they went through me I
feel like kids opposed to take over
whether their parents left off you know
parents build it to a certain point kids
supposed to be working out training
playing sports going to school getting
good grades and when they get old enough
you're supposed to take where your
parents left off and build up on that
not go your ass back home and putting
the milk putting your name on the milk
and stuff like that you know that's not
what it's about you know I really
believe your parents and I always say
this to my kid and say it's a bunch of
kids your parents are raising you to
leave the house once back in there to
stuff let me see if I got any shots
right here real quick yeah you guys man
there's a guy I'm a defensive guy who
sounds right
there's a lot of blue in between there
yeah let me get this cigar going starts
out to the fans that's over here I got a
couple folks out here I know y'all don't
have a live audience we gotta do it
right bleep man I feel like I'm shooting
one of Martin shows yeah
who who taught you game of football what
you learned man when I was born mammy I
always say I was born to play football
you know it was just in me you know my
dad was a super athlete played
everything I played every sport baseball
basketball ran track soccer you know so
I always said I was born to play
football you know and truly it was one
of the only ways out of my neighborhood
in Metairie you know I'm saying so when
I was five years old my brother tossed
me the ball and like get past me my
older brother you know I played a lot of
street football you know I'm saying pole
the pole lamppost a lamppost mailbox the
mailbox I got to scar my head from
running into a mailbox when I was like
12 years old I caught the ball - how did
that happen
I gotta hear this story because I know
that you're Hall of Fame bus everyone
always talks about how beautiful that
buses the attention to detail to that
bus man I got a picture like seven years
old I always had hair on my head
but on being that football is such a
physical sport you know I uh I felt like
having a little cushion you know I'm
saying well helping me out you know you
get football's violent sport a lot of
concussions stingers and stuff like that
man so I know it's just it was in my
nature it's part of my culture you know
you know I see like like we're dealing
with a lot of ignorant stuff these days
man especially when it comes to kids at
school and their hair you know like just
one kid in Texas they acts in the kid to
cut it yeah the kid run assistance for a
long time like that has nothing to do
with school but that's the ignorance
that we're dealing with you know so for
me to wear it like this you know I know
I need to cut it that turns but it's
just natural to me man I'm comfortable
in my own skin and that's what it's
about you got to be comfortable with who
you are I got here the mailbox story
okay so you caught the pass but what
happened did you see the mailbox with a
yo UCAN fan so are you doing a Marlon
King shot right here on me right now man
I am part of um nah man we was playing
on the spot called the playground and
the guy threw the ball and I'm running
like this I'm running looking for the
ball but it's you know it's
I'm out running the ball basically so
I'm looking at it like this right here
and as I catch the ball I'll hit the
mailbox and you know our kids are I got
the ball in my hand they like let us see
let us see and I move my hand and
nothing for blood I passed out after
that on my dad do all the next thing I
heard was like your dad's going your way
on his way to come get you you know so I
probably my first concussion but you get
stitches a surgeon when I have stitches
I stitch I like 16 stitches man how long
it take for it to heal look for life I'm
still bruised I gotta ask you so you
your guy who grows up in the New Orleans
area it feels like you were born to play
football why did you choose Miami y'all
might want to stand up and look and say
why not my don't stand by those stairs
man I mean I wanted to get away from
home you know I'm saying I felt like my
my environment was not um not healthy
enough for me to do the things that I
wanted to do I grew up around on my way
to school man I'll pass up three
plantations on my way to high school
I'll pass up three plantations you know
I do it I did it on golf tournament five
minutes from my high school not even you
could walk to this golf course in 1990
my mentor they were still not able to go
to this golf course as black people
you're talking to 90s you know I'm
saying so I just didn't want to be
around people who just had that
old-school mentality you know I'm saying
like that's still in the South you know
you still see it in Mississippi my
people are from Mississippi my family's
from Mississippi with the Prison Reform
situation yeah absolutely
you know I'm saying so that stuff that
stuff means something to me man I'm a
people's person I used to live with my
mom secretary of my high school she's
white lady you know a family Caucasian
white you know so I live with them
that's my family you know so I sought a
I see things different man I'm not I
don't know I'm not
I'll hear judging people and your race
I'll do that you know it is what it is
but I wanted to get away from that man
and I felt like I felt like Miami was
gonna be different and come to find out
it wouldn't do my suit but I really
wanted me I wanted to win the national
championship you know I wanted I wanted
to win the national championship and
thank God we did you know I actually got
my ring on right here you know so that
was about to me man I was about playing
playing at the highest level but put
myself in position to also make it to
the NFL
you know I was a businessman at a young
age man that 2001 team considered one of
the greatest if not the greatest you
think it's the greatest yeah yeah I mean
I don't have to I don't have to shout
out the records I don't have to shout
out the first rounders but i'ma just
talk about two people myself and Sean
Taylor show and tell it was my backup he
wouldn't even start then and he's a
beast hall-of-famer in my eyes you know
I'm saying and I rolled those guys like
that Jonathan Vilma our first rounders
you know I'm saying so we we we was on
another level in college but it was
about our coaching staff that's what
people don't talk about it's the people
who are guiding you man everybody should
have a mentor you know it said but we
had men raising young men you know I'm
saying and that's what it was about you
know you got like you need guidance as a
young man as a kid when you get to
college women young young ladies and
young men or become a midni when they
get to college you know it's the real
world people growing up so much faster
exactly exactly they have access to
everything right at the touch of their
hand you know so I don't man we just had
a great coaching staff we had super
bowl-winning coaches coach Davis Curtis
Johnson Chuck Pagano our Kehoe I can
name so many got Mario crystal ball
who's head coach at Oregon now we had a
lot of great men leading young men and
that's what we need now we need us men
to lead our men you know I'm certainly
these
these young kids we need that more you
see the women doing it
women gonna be over taking over this
world so I'm with that though I mean we
gonna have us a woman president you know
running this thing because I mean they
they stand together you know I mean they
stick together you see all kinds of
women groups doing all kinds of things
man you know and we need that we need to
stand up as men and and take hold of
what we supposed to do - is your shot
yeah actually I shot okay how are you
gonna make it made nothing yet I'll give
you a shot knowing somewhat thank you
you may hope charity donation will help
you out now look I went to Arizona State
I also grew up in Texas wouldn't escape
my situation as well and I went had the
same experience you did in Miami like
well I had what I want to go anywhere
else
mm-hmm Arizona State is a party school I
had a good time in my four years but I
was in a prominent football player at
the University of Miami were what was
the party scene like what was it like
being the man on campus and the man in
Miami the party scene could wait I never
came to the beach when I was in college
I never crossed that bridge when I was
in college you know I understood to do
the things that I wanted to do man I
needed to be around my teammates and
stay close to that school don't get me
wrong week we had some times when we you
know when I got I was older man I was 21
22 when I graduated
you know I stayed five years so it's how
you handle things man at the end of the
day you know I'm saying I had a lot of
fun but when I got to my senior just
talk about my senior year we didn't
party during the week we parted after
the game we can get you do whatever you
want after the game but that week man
just chill out why because it's a
focused time man it's work you know you
got you you playing a physical sport we
put a lot into as I say I put my heart
in this [ __ ] you know in all season as
we did let's not waste this opportunity
high school college goes by like that
even a career
in FL it goes by like that I'm 41 years
old man and retired from from football
like I'm very tired but people ask me
what I do and go to the bank and I'll be
like I'm retired you'd be like what
retired but now I say semi retired semi
retired retired from football but I
still do other things you know I'm
saying so you got to have a plan man you
know I'm saying so I knew that it was a
short-lived career in in college I knew
it was gonna go by like that and I
wanted to enjoy it every morning man I
got to ask you about one specific moment
why I'll take a shot real quick I heard
you got a story about Shannon Briggs who
was standing brace Shannon Briggs raises
a boxer yeah yeah a champion boxer
very neat box how big we talking it man
Shannon Shannon Briggs I mean when he
stood up he's looking like King Kong
what six five begins but he's huge man
it's solid too when I say you solid man
what what happened word on the street is
you and Shannon Briggs whoa whoa whoa
had a little something something to
happen what happened that night
and did you know he's even Shannon
Briggs I didn't know we didn't know he
was Shannon Briggs so what happened long
story short we got this click now I need
the long story I need the long yeah I
gave the whole story we got a group
denied in the Class of 95 class in 97
Class of 95 was known as two genes could
they graduate in 2002 jeez - jeez okay
so it's me and Bryan McKinney Brian
McKinney and I'd jungus ones with them
hanging out and we're on the beach now
we didn't cross the bridge right and
that's why we never cross the bridge the
numbered row so we come to the beach
with the older guys me and Brian killing
the young guys we in the club and one of
the older guys come back in like you
don't gotta come on let's go let's go um
when our teammates this got knocked out
like knocked out you got in the fight
let's go so we like all right cool we
walking through the arm we walk through
the back of the club in the alley then
we walk
through the alley to Collins as we
coming through I'm actually in the front
and the guy you know my man was like
they right there
so I'm looking like so what's up man
like why y'all jumped on our boy why you
not why you knocked him out and lo and
behold he jumps up you won't sell like
debo you want some - all right no but I
got a bunch of cash with me so who was
with you we me Brian McKinney I just
leave that day in like 502 G when you
save the kitty I know Brian okay because
when he said that and I'm like nah man
we're just trying to figure out Brian
McKinney come through Brian McKinney is
if you never saw Brian McKinney how big
is he
brian Kinney is like six nine 300
something at this time needless to say
Brian McKinney didn't give up a sack in
Miami so Brian McKinney comes through
way way wait get the he was like get the
little guy so there's two of them
Shannon Briggs in the friend or whatever
so I come around whatever hit the little
guy he's pretty much out of there Brian
grab Shannon Briggs by his dreads yanked
him down like he's the white Freni he's
on the ground man and they just they
wailing on him now I mean they're going
to town on him right and he's just on
the ground on his all forces taking it
so I go over to bout time I get over
there man this guy's just took off
running out of the group he's getting
kicked all kinds of stuff right so we go
back in the club like man I'm done ready
to go home now man we got to find our
boy though so we finally getting we're
on
we're like Collins and 17 so how far is
that from here right in this location
we're into myself because right now it's
a lot of two streets always like we are
17 right now like this is 17 we like
right here and he's at Nikki Beach Nikki
Beach is
as is Ocean and one knows it in firstly
you like how do you get down there that
quick you ran down there dude hey sailor
breeze kick you know so that mean that's
kind of high hat man that next day do we
have practice we walking out there sore
like we got in a boxing fight we didn't
know that it was Shannon Briggs at the
time you know I'm standing until he
actually got sued by my boy because he
broke his jaw you know you can't boxers
can't fight on the street there's a
weapons you know so he wound up getting
suit and everything you know I'm saying
so so neither side you cool with
standard Briggs now what's the relation
I never even met him man no I'm sorry
and I hope you're not watching this
right now that will take that from from
there and go straight to the NFL okay
you're finishing up your rookie year in
the NFL with the Ravens you say you flip
the switch after your rookie year why
yeah cuz I understood to have when you
get to the NFL you hear not for long and
it's true man average NFL careers with
three seasons yeah that's because the
numbers are skewed because of free
agents coming in and out all the time
it's a cutthroat business man I always
said it was like the drug game nobody
they don't get they get rid of you in a
minute
so when I got there you here not for
long I was like no I need I need for
longevity you know I'm saying like I
want to get longevity out of this I want
to have a career I want to play a long
time cuz you spent your whole childhood
prepping for this career yeah man and
you know I got a hurricane that with me
and Ray Lewis you know and I already
knew a bunch of stuff about work ethic
working on stuff man but Ray had a chef
you know he was living a certain way
ride a mansion in Baltimore you know so
it went so much it's like let me get the
mansion and everything but the things
that at least I can say if I wanted I
can get it you know I'm saying there's a
difference between one in the need you
know
and I didn't want it I didn't need it
you know but if I can say now well I'm
at now I'll [ __ ] if I wanted I can go by
but at the same time you gotta have to
upkeep so I was like man you gotta eat
right you gotta work out you gotta train
and quite frankly I did enough having
enough good time here in Miami and
college to where I could put the
partying down and that's what I did you
know me and I'm a kid he used to go out
all the time
man Brian Kenny lives right directly
across from me in the condo is a
Brickell and he know I'm not lying he's
that his party bus they used to pick up
everybody man come on Reid come on
downstairs I'm like what's to talk about
they're like we going out I look off the
balcony man I'm not getting on that bus
you know but yeah now put it down like
read you changed you changed read and I
did man I was when was he saying you
changed when people notice that I mean I
was reading a word more you know and and
just finding myself you know I was
hoping myself I was 23
you know anything killing that old guy
that that that was I felt like what's
dragging me down you know I'm saying
that could be people it could be
yourself you know is what if you feel
like you've been dragged down man
you got to change some things you know
as me and my boy say you got to take
inventory on yourself and your
surroundings the people you surround
yourself with that's real the show shall
miss it why you would talk about a South
Beach story I couldn't focus so couldn't
get locked in but you gave me one
already gave me some donation so on top
of the Miami Hurricanes you always wear
them on a rope like that Jayde's I see
you got the the Raven strength ring on
sue
yeah Edison I feel like this is Miami
thinker the first person I saw it do it
was Trick Daddy oh yeah yeah what do you
see him do it man this is back when I
used to be running with Trick Trick took
care of us took care of my family you
know at times when I was here in Miami
you know and my trick tend to get a bad
rep man but he's a really good do man
and he truly do cares about the kids you
know and um he loved Miami and when I
was here man I should always be around
him in this homeboy 22 and just just
hanging around and if something was
about to happen here let me know Reid
you need to get up out of here get your
family let's go you know but uh he was
the first person I actually saw to do
this and I just kind of take it from
there maybe I always called him on I'll
call him uncle trick you know I haven't
seen him in a while but yeah man he he
was a big part he was a big part of
growth yeah for me and in college so you
got the twin twelves and their Super
Bowl ring wrapped around your neck as
well no no this is my Hall of Fame right
your Hall of Fame ring oh yeah yes the
B's I can't fit I don't think nobody
here could put this on their finger
where's your super eager the Super Bowl
ring is actually back at the hotel
um the diamond off the first Super Bowl
came off so we gotta get that fixed yeah
but I wasn't a part of that one anyways
oh I'm not trippin what do you take away
from that year though cuz that you guys
during that season
you got your ass what about of Texas
yeah there was a bye week that happen
then afterwards what happened to him
practiced that week man we we had a
meeting with the coach we had a meeting
with coach Harbaugh before the team
meeting team meetings at 8:30 we had an
8 o'clock meeting with the head coach of
his office he's like Coco guys I'm
thinking about putting your own pass for
the bye week we were like coach no way
we're not doing pads man in the bye week
you know like we older team we don't
need that yeah right he was like long
story short he was like I all right I'm
not gonna do it we're not gonna put you
guys in pads man we walk right
downstairs and coaches like all right
we're gonna put you guys in pull pass
who's I know that's how I raised my hand
like coach come on man you just said you
know you wouldn't go do that can't go
back on your word he was like yeah and I
changed my mind walking down the stairs
I'm like no no man you can't you can't
do that to us man you know so that later
- Bernard polish getting up standing up
and then it got heated at some point
Bernard is yelling that coach Harbaugh
it was like tell him and I'm like war I
already said what I you know he threw me
back in that fire man and I you know I I
charmed in but it really it really
resonated with Haloti Ngata who don't
say nothing he's a gentle giant as my
guy and everybody know hello they don't
say much how Lord he was like coach you
did tell us that and when hollowed he
said it the team backed it and that
right there brought us together
you know I'm saying ouch that was that
was going into the playoffs man we had
to go to Denver we had to go to New
England you know I'm saying oh yeah man
we was already on that as I could use
now on that Mamba mentality of everyday
working hard man and quiet could tell
you ray can tell you scissor could tell
you everyday we did the same stuff all
the way up into the Super Bowl you know
I'm saying we had some bumps in there
there's some speed bumps that you got to
go over that's natural that's life you
know but it was it was it was something
that really brought us together what are
you always gonna take away from that
season man the memories man just being
with my boys that practice you know the
dedication that they put into it the
discipline practice practice is one of
those memories that are always gonna pop
up for you oh yeah man a locker room you
know we had a cornhole tournament that
year and of course they got all the time
in the world
I kick in the snap to be funny and there
you walk in there they throwing car hose
you know so that was that man I was
something that but that was just
bringing us together I remember we used
to tell the guys don't eat at the
facility at the practice and we used to
all go to Yuki sushi and just have
drinks in just sitting there managed to
get no getting to know your teammates
away from the football field you know
that's very important to know your
co-workers who you working with me how
they are you know I'm saying
how are they gonna handle things away
from the business that tells you live
you
so I you might see I did this I did it
on sit down with Joe Buck and I put I
put my teammates on blast but I had
already did it in the meeting while I
told them like bruh we got volunteer
firemen around here and y'all grown men
throwing your trash right in front of
the garbage can and they wouldn't miss
it and leave it there cuz they know
somebody was gonna take care of it you
know or leave their tile in the shower
make imagine being in the locker room
going into the lot in the shower in
dirty towels or everywhere on the damn
knob that you got to turn the water on
what you take that as a sign of when you
saw that disrespect is disgusting and
that stuff kids do I'm correcting my son
on this y'all doing it no way man this
is your house away from your house your
home away from home you know I'm saying
when I lost my brother in 2011
those were my family members to hold me
together so this is our home but more
than more than anything respect those
firing men dude they're grown men do
they shouldn't have to be picking up
after you they not your maids you know
I'm saying and if we want to win a
championship me and Ray had this
conversation my rookie year he was just
like bro we got to do the little things
man
the little things if you don't do the
little things it turn the big stuff
there's always alpha males and egos in
the locker room you and Ray Lewis or two
alpha males that I feel like in terms of
a leadership perspective kind of
approach things differently yeah but it
seemed like you always were able to miss
yeah why cuz man look I didn't care I
think here who got the glory man I come
from Miami where we had many stars we
had a lot of first rounders I come from
Miami where we were pushing each other
to be great that's what I come from
around and that's what it's about
that's enough out here for everybody to
have they print money all the time they
print money as we speak that's enough
for everybody so all we got to do is
just encourage each other if we work
together if we work together we're gonna
win and everybody will have an
opportunity to do something to be in the
lead my whole senior class had an
opportunity to go to
NFL and went to a team what'd you do
with the opportunities on yours I was
gonna put mine in a chokehold as DC
young fly was safe shout-out to my boys
but real stuff when you get that
opportunity man you got to put it in the
chokehold because if you don't somebody
else especially at the University of
Miami was right behind you waiting for
the opportunity as you shared Shawn say
was behind you real stuff and I wouldn't
happen it wouldn't happen it wouldn't
happen no I'm playing with three broken
legs how beneficial was it for you to
have Ray Lewis at the start of your
career in the NFL to kind of show the
leadership and guidance of how to adjust
to the professional level Manu is key to
have Ray Peter Boulware Derrick Mason
Matt Stover it was a lot of leaders man
it was not just one leader you know I
know the people always saw me with Ray
and we were we would like peas in the
pocket with hurricanes we were always
together but it was Monty Sanders who
was with us to our trainer you know Sam
Rohan Marley
that was with us we trained Jamaica
together so it wasn't just Rain Man you
know I'm saying it was many people cuz
not every time man race all right you
know I'm saying but I didn't care I
don't care I didn't care who get the
glory man I can care less about that
like I said it's enough for everybody
I'm gonna take my little bit have me a
cigar and keep it moving
I think it's your shot I was myself it's
you're sure I make one but if it's not
your shot I give it to you because you
need some help let me get this for you
got a lot of kids in the street you feel
charitable how was it like for you to
win a Super Bowl we had we had Jacoby
Jones on season one also New Orleans
Nader that dad how low-tack talking has
my boy season one we talked to him about
being able to win in two worlds yeah
winning the Super Bowl in new ones yeah
I want to ask you up that take the
shower with we can I'm saying yeah help
you up
what was it like for you as a New
Orleans native yeah I'm from New Orleans
I would say city so for for us to go
back home it was everything to me man
so the week we're going to New Orleans
for the Super Bowl I had to give a
speech to the guys about not eating a
lot of food cuz I'm like dude come
Wednesday Thursday don't be eating all
this food man you're gonna be heavy and
sluggish I want to give you a spoiler
alert Jacoby Jones did not listen his
mama was cooking gumbo and everything my
mom cook too for the guys listen
everybody copy shitty IVP at two
touchdowns kickoff return come on man
this is real you know so I'm like guys
be mindful man eat the food you know
saying I've brought crawfish and
everything to the hotels for the boys
you know but we we still on a business
trip so treat it as such you know and
plus ma'am in my backyard I'm not losing
in my backyard you know saying I ate
oysters every day so I know how horses
would do for you pregame I was jacked up
you know said I actually hurt myself in
the first quarter I hurt both of my MCL
is I sprained both of them yeah yeah man
so but but to do it at home and it was a
true block I can't really even describe
winning the championship at home you
know I'm saying we was the last team to
play in the Superdome before Katrina hit
right we were the first team to play in
the Super Bowl in New Orleans after
Katrina so for me it's a lot man special
man there's so much you know I look at
Baltimore New Orleans as Twin Cities
because of the stuff that they
experienced in the inner cities
economically the way em have you watched
your made you watch the wire
st. you get a real good glimpse of how
the cities are you know so it was
special to me man and now Baltimore New
Orleans people when they get together
man it's a blast it's a party so that
was it uh
remark yes all right now I made two real
quick you know I'm saying anyone
embarrass myself so my shot
quit me from wrong that was your last
game as a raven that was my last game as
a raven unfortunately yes
did you know what's gonna in there I had
that clue I had a clue it was going in
there because when Ray Lewis became a
free agent I was at the house with him
and they didn't offer him too much so
it's a businessman I learned a lot from
Steve bisciotti Ozzie Newsome those guys
you know and they taught me so much
excuse me for turning my back to you
guys but they taught me so much about
the business so I wasn't surprised when
I called because I didn't have an agent
I was my own agent I called and I'm like
what's going on what we doing and they
were like we don't have nothing for you
I'm like not even a dollar they didn't
offer me a dollar not a dime so I was
like all right my time is up you know my
time is up because I was alright with it
I think I said in Super Bowl is a MCN
sprain was a tear wasn't I had a
second-degree MCL sprain on my left leg
in the first degree on my right so as
much as I wanted to pick off three and
four picks from Kaepernick because I
knew I had him I couldn't move you know
I'm saying and be honest with you that
was we played the Saints in the
Superdome so many times that was the
only interception I ever had in the
Superdome yeah man we party one time
down there like 2006 we was kicking a
buck and the boys on the sidelines
dancing doing everything everybody from
Louisiana we had like five guys on the
team from Louisiana everybody except for
me caught interception that game but in
the Super Bowl when it counts the Hogs
settled up you stepped up desert so the
Ravens are seeing you coming off the
injury in the Super Bowl in the Super
Bowl you're getting older your time's up
there you end up spending time with the
Houston Texans you reunited with Andre
Johnson if I just stayed in Baltimore
I'd still be playing today you think so
I know so why because man I just had I
had everything going the right way
I had my doctor training everything when
I went to Houston they took me back to
the south and it was so discouraging
if y'all remember recipes to him bobbing
their butt out of respect if y'all
remember when we were going through
certain things in NFL you remember he
said you can't let the prisoners run the
prison he was the guy say that I saw
that before I saw that when I was in
when I was there you know they went the
way he ran things are with how the
Houston weights are to say that they
called it you know and it's not the city
it's the organization you know at the
time and they had that old-school
mentality man you had coaches talking
reckless to guys you know and I'm like
as a grown man how do you let that
happen and Plus as a coach you're not
gonna get everything out of that man
that you want because you're talking to
him reckless I was surrounded by a bunch
of guys just coming to work it was a job
it wasn't football anymore and for me
that was like draining that was very
draining man and and you actually bought
me in recruiting me and asked me to tell
you the things that I'm telling you and
when I started saying that stuff
they showed me off you know it was like
huh that's that's not how we do it
so I was lied to I'm too old to be lied
to and I'm too old to play these games
with people who you know say you got to
play the game to get higher I'm not
playing the game I got time for that I
go do something else you know I'm saying
I go work back at Blockbuster yeah I
worked at Blockbuster when I was here in
college so kids you can have a job so
you went from there then you went to the
Jets and then how'd you know it was time
to hang it up at that point cuz you're
sharing right now that you feel like the
really only reason I retired it was to
bring some joy to Baltimore Freddie gray
had just got killed man and I was
sitting in my house in Georgia it was
like you know what I'm done you know
I'll let these young folk have it let
let one of these young kids make the
roster and let him make some money man
I'm good I took care of my finance and
still take care of my finance or I
wasn't I wasn't one of those old guys
like need to stay plan you know so I was
like bring some joy back home and I
started building my foundation up in
Baltimore even more why'd you feel was
on
you to bring the city joy through your
retirement during a really rough time
for that city cuz I mean I was in that
light you know it was kind of like Kobe
man you're in there light what can you
do you know how how can cuz all we here
to do is leave this place a better place
than we got it when we came you know so
that's the man my adviser Glen my
director my foundation started talking
about doing more stuff in the community
man we went I went from my first year
started my foundation feeding 30 people
with my financial adviser Brad Davis
feeding 30 people we used to go to the
store ourselves pick up the bags pick up
the turkeys the fixings and everything
excuse me and bag it ourselves bringing
to Booker T Washington we went from 30
to now 20 years later feed like 5,000
yeah you know so that's incredible
that's what it's about that's incredible
you know that that's what it's about but
I felt like you know I was getting calls
from the White House like call like make
an Instagram post to the kids and tell
him to go home during the Baltimore
riots I said there's got to be the
stupidest thing I ever heard why because
they know nobody who's riding is looking
at the damn phone they damn sure I know
they're taking pictures like we all here
getting stuff I'm not about to do that
and who could you relate to more the
White House or these kids Pro two kids
cuz I know why it got to that point I
worked with Booker T Washington in
Baltimore they don't get these kids a
chance these kids come down the street
and there's more abandoned buildings
just like you've seen on the wire they
walking past those abandoned buildings
they might have one that's a being
housed you know I'm saying so these kids
go to school with no hope in Baltimore
man you know I'm saying so it was easy
for me to deny that because they're the
root of it the government won't allow
you to do nothing in the schools the
government allow you to take care of our
kids the kids are our future how how as
a human being as a grown person that you
deny a kid opportunity a kid is innocent
you got kids raising kids in Baltimore
man because they mamas are strung out on
stuff
you know I'm saying that's around the
world but what I know in Baltimore we
need help we need helping in it and
don't get me wrong Baltimore is not a
bad city we got a bad rap well you gonna
visit Baltimore have a good time you
gonna have a great time I have a good
time you have a great time man go visit
go visit bygone and well you can't get
an elk room unless you know me you with
me Uncle John you know but they got
another lot of nice spots and be more
you know I'm saying well you can go and
enjoy yourself and have a good time and
a lot of History Day you know admired
I mean we can go to your Hall of Fame
speech now you're wearing the Hall of
Fame ring around your neck
I admired how you use the platform to
speak about black lives matter and
police brutality you spoke earlier about
how you felt the the platform that you
had and the prominence that you have the
weight on your shoulders to do these
things and speak out on these issues
yeah but why in that particular space
when everyone's celebrating you that you
decide to give light on black lives
matter please protect cuz that moment
wasn't about me I didn't get there by
myself so why am I gonna get up there
and talk about it you already saw a
highlight reel you know saying you
already know what II did not you want to
know what what was ed off the football
field what what who were the people in
his life you know to help him get to the
kid to that point what are the things
that affect you as a human being you
know I'm saying and that's the time to
do it you know nothing to him but that's
why I thought tio should've went because
now you have the platform to say all the
things you want to say you know so for
me it was just it was just trying to
bring light to the world man like all
police are not bad dude my brother's a
police officer I mean he played mean um
he's actually Miami Beach police you
know so it's just so much man that that
was on my mind a lot of stuff actually
left out because he's like hitting the
time you know they only give you like 10
minutes or 15 minutes this morning to
let everybody speak as long as they
wanted exactly it is I mean it gets long
you know saying you got a lot of old
guys they're sitting there I'm gonna be
there this year better every year
smoking a cigar
you know listening to my guys but that's
the time man that which you can bring
light to the world man you can you can
help somebody out you know you can you
can talk about issues that affected you
and people would never know like
thinking you're perfect people people
put us on a high pedestal because we
played a sport when I and all actual
reality we're human just like everybody
else we're no different we just worked
our ass off the plate to be really good
just watch you work your ass off you can
do the same thing it's no different it
really is to see you know the heart got
to be there you know I'm saying so I
think that we human beings man and
that's what I tell a lot of pictures I
got my gram I'd be like no pics you know
I got just no pig thing going around cuz
it's out of hand man that's a camera
everywhere and it's not just these
cameras it's the cameras you got in your
phone in your pocket you know everybody
got a camera from from a seven eight
year old to a 88 year old you know and
everybody feel like they're entitled to
your time your picture come on man I'm
just as human as you walking down the
street hey what's up man cool how you
doing it's like you seen your boy down
just walking up the street walking on a
side street what's up bro you holla at
him
keep it moving that's how you should be
back in the old days before all these
phones and cable line technology change
there but that's mine that's that's part
of my grape in this world is that the
forefathers didn't foresee that when
they wrote the Constitution and all that
stuff you see what I'm saying so we're
still living under some of those laws
man we're still living under some of
those ways and they didn't foresee the
internet they didn't foresee that stuff
that stuff affects our livelihood
different hey I could talk to you for
like another five or six hours I got
time it's hell we got to wrap it up here
but it thank you so much for taking the
time out during the Super Bowl we spent
time here on told stories this perfect
way for us to wrap up season one I wish
you nothing but the best this week as we
also celebrates you on Sunday at the
Super Bowl during NFL 100 being a member
of that congratulations on that as well
so thank you for the time and I also
want to in this game for you bust my ass
where's my shot on a ball I appreciate
y'all having me here finish though real
quick
taking the time I jogged a to come watch
those two pool and let me smoke a cigar
and bust you down and poo I'm gonna put
it right here you got right here it's a
scratch shot I'm gonna try not to
scratch let's play this out real quick
listen you go do your thing
let's see if we complain you got a lot
of kids in the street all day I'm trying
to do is get from under these cooking
lights chicken roasted right now turning
won't be a dream coaching job my dream
coaching job probably head coach it'll
definitely be head coaching and I can't
live in myself I won't let me myself I
coach anywhere man you know almost
anywhere because it depends on who your
boss who you work for that's in any
profession man your boss a jerk you
gonna be giving it every day you know if
your boss in the NFL don't like his wife
you don't want to go home you owe me
that a long time you know so I'm gonna
put it right there mo you got it cuz
they slice everything I wrap it up right
here I'm hoping you kind of scratch low
key
hey go scratch you want to win like that
oh that's like when we have I can get it
feel me
that is true a wins a win let's wrap
this up and go so we got any San Fran
fans in here no you guys just shot right
there
KC friends okay let's say Fran fan right
there who's winning the game
hey my man why sell you by yourself you
better be careful man everyone right now
you made it man haha hey man oh man
thank you so much joy thank you no doubt
man appreciate you guys for tuning in
thanks to supporting this all season
long I'm a spy so I'm out see you guys
season two thanks for kicking it with us
subscribe to be our to check out more
dope videos like this one